إنهم يستعدون لجبهة ثانية خطيرة
ولكننا حصلنا على وصول حصري إلى
الحدود الشمالية المتوترة لإسرائيل، وقد أغلق الجيش الإسرائيلي الآن
كمنطقة أمنية بعض
المناطق القريبة من الحدود اللبنانية
بسبب التهديد الذي يشكله ولكنهم
إنهم يأخذوننا
الآن إلى أقرب فترة، أقرب
مكان يمكنهم القيام به، ويقولون إنه مكان آمن
لرؤية
الأرض وهذه الأرض معادية، ولم يرغب أي من
الجنود الإسرائيليين هنا في
إظهار وجوههم لإخفاء هوياتهم
عن حزب الله القوي
ميليشيا لبنانية لديها ترسانة ضخمة مدربة على
هذه المواقع عبر الحدود،
نحن مستعدون إذا اختاروا المجيء فسوف
يرتكبون خطأً فادحًا، فالحرب مع
حزب الله ستكون وحشية، قال هذا
القائد الإسرائيلي الكبير الذي طلب عدم
الكشف عن هويته،
لكنها كذلك  الآن أصبح من الضروري أيضًا أن يخبرني
هل تعتقد أنه ستكون هناك
جبهة ثانية مفتوحة هنا أم أنك لا تزال متفائلًا
بأن حزب الله سيبقى خارج هذه
الحرب. آمل أن تكون هناك جبهة أخرى
نحتاج إليها لتدميرك، تأمل أن
تكون هناك جبهة أخرى.  نريد الحرب،
نعم
لماذا ما حدث في غزة لم يأت من
العدم، بل جاء من كيسالا، بل جاء
من إيران، ولكي نوقف
ما
حدث من كاماس، علينا أن نوقفهم
أيضًا، حسنًا، هذا أقرب ما يكون إلى
يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي إن بإمكاننا المرور
عبر الأراضي اللبنانية التي
يسيطر عليها حزب الله،
والميليشيا اللبنانية والجنود الإسرائيليون في هذا
الموقع في إسرائيل، ويخبروننا أنه
خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية كانت هناك
محاولات متعددة من قبل مقاتلي حزب الله
لاختراق السياج والدخول إليه.  يأتون إلى
إسرائيل ولكن تم صدهم إذا كانت هناك
جبهة ثانية في
هذه الحرب في إسرائيل، فمن المرجح
أنها ستبدأ
هنا بالفعل، وقد حدث تبادل
لإطلاق النار أجبر الإسرائيليين المحليين على الفرار
مذعورين مما حدث في
جنوب إسرائيل  يمكن أن يحدث هنا أيضًا
هجوم إرهابي بهذا الحجم لم يحدث أبدًا
وأخشى أنني أعيش على الحدود
فما الذي يمنعهم من القيام بذلك هنا
وأريد أن أكون قويًا وأريد
العودة والعيش هنا ولكني  أحتاج إلى
التفكير في أطفالي
أولاً بعد عودتهم من الحدود. تقوم إسرائيل
بتعزيز قواتها ببعض من
360 ألف جندي تم حشدهم بعد
هجمات حماس الأسبوع الماضي. إذا كانت الحرب في الشمال
قادمة، تبدو إسرائيل مستعدة حتى
للقتال. ماثيو تشانس سي إن إن شمال
إسرائيل